look out for the man running on the road
he's trying to jump up on a lorry
heading for britain and he's not alone
in that ambition
[Music]
we saw dozens of attempts beneath this
sign a group of men all waiting for
their turn to try to jump on a lorry
sometimes they succeed this man clambers
up the side and jams himself between the
cab and the trailer
but most are spotted they jump off and
simply wander away back into the night
ready to try again
people have died on these roads but that
seems no deterrent
it's very dangerous to go on the lorry
no
no
no no
in the small hours there are people
lurking all around maybe hundreds at a
time
and the role of policing them falls to
specialist units
it is rare to hear from officers like
this they don't want to be named
but what comes across is frustration
one by one
that come
and try from this
to jump in the lorries
every night every night the same thing
every night every night every night is
it getting worse
yes for about
four or five months it's worse and worse
and worse
look
he just wait and when we go he will come
back here
i see everything and i see everything
twice
yeah and every day
every day and every night
the team receives a call we join them
and end up at a large lorry park it's
clear that people have broken in
so the police unit will have arrived
here to discover that the razor wire
that was at the top of this fence has
been pulled down so you can leap over
the top their problem is that the people
who did this damage have already
disappeared it's a classic example of
the cat and mouse game that is being
played constantly by the french police
here in calais
they check the vehicles but if there are
people here they're well hidden
the team moves on they find more damage
but finding the culprits is almost
impossible the police role here is about
deterrence and dispersal
on this road they fire tear gas as a
gathering crowd but when the police go
these men will return
in this game of cat and mouse the mice
always come back
among lorry drivers nervousness we found
this vehicle sliced open by a would-be
stowaway
drivers face a fine of up to 2 000
pounds for bringing a migrant into
britain even if they've got no idea
someone's on board
this man drives between poland and
britain every week he checks his vehicle
scrupulously
we do all we can what we can we do you
must be
checking all that carefully because it
is a big problem
on the motorway nearby branches have
been thrown onto the carriageway to slow
down lorries it's a familiar tactic
the migrants here often spend months
doing this every night hoping to get
lucky hoping to survive
and hoping to get a lift to britain
adam parsons sky news cali